[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
there's probably a lot of videos in your
subscription box right around now i'm
glad you clicked this one this one will
be a little different this is your
official unboxing of the google pixel 2
and the google pixel 2 xl retail
packaging so by the time you're seeing
this video i've already had a pixel 2
for around a week and i'm putting
together the full review right now
literally as you're watching this but i
did want to give you guys a few quick
thoughts as i'm finishing testing so
obviously we can get these first
impressions in the crowded hands-on area
that was a little while ago but seeing
the phone again in your own hands is
always a little bit of a different
experience so you can see everything
here that comes in the box for both
pixel 2 and pixel 2 xl wall adapter usb
c cables
2017 smartphone starter kit dongle the
whole deal this unboxing is of course of
the pixel but then of course what do you
know i've been testing the xl so mine is
already fully set up so this is our
second look at the phone and of course
it's our second look at these bezels in
real life but honestly the more i look
at them the less ugly they look and i
feel like they may also be necessary for
the squeeze feature to activate google
assistant but i'll definitely have more
on that in the full review and also the
soft touch metal all the way around the
body of this phone has held up pretty
well it's a pretty medium to lightweight
phone uh but it holds up to pretty much
zero scratch damage and it's
surprisingly good at repelling
fingerprints with whatever oleophobic
coating they're using on it i like it
but really what i wanted to dive into in
this video is to show that basically in
the time that i've been using this phone
and the previous generations it's become
pretty obvious that the differentiating
factor when you're trying to pick which
of these phones to buy for this one it's
the software the software experience
with android 8.0 oreo on the pixel 2
it's full of
little things and little features you
might call it polish but to me it's just
kind of things that make you go
oh yeah that's that's that's really nice
that's a good thing they thought of that
that's maybe the best way i can describe
it so while this isn't the most stunning
hardware in the world there is a lot of
cool stuff going on in the software
department so let's break it down number
one the settings app is redone and
cleaned up and sorted so different
android skins handle the ever increasing
number of extra features in android in
different ways you know some of them
spread them out more some of them are
very colorful this one is more into
nesting the less used features but
overall i think this is super clean you
have a consistent theme you have the
search function that works really really
well it's white and blue so it's really
easy on the eyes i'm a big fan of the
settings app in this new version of
android now number two is the now
playing feature which is pretty freaking
incredible so this is the feature that's
supposed to proactively tell you what
song is playing where you are on your
phone before you have to even ask it to
it works most of the time not all the
time but a lot of the times when you
experience that sort of a desire to know
what song's playing when you're in like
a coffee shop or in some place where
music is playing it's usually a pretty
popular song and that's why it works
often but it's using the always-on mics
on this phone and it's using pixels
ambient services to pull from a pool of
tens of thousands of songs which doesn't
sound like much but that's usually
enough based on like we said where
you're hearing these songs but basically
when it does recognize one of the songs
you're listening to it works as
advertised it shows up on your lock
screen you can drag down your
notifications and actually click on that
song that it's identified for you and
maybe play it on youtube or add it to a
spotify playlist whatever you want to do
with it it's pretty solid the only
downside was i did get rick rolled
recently i know you're judging me for
that but it was actually way funnier
like three minutes later when i saw
never gonna give you up on my lock
screen thanks internet now number three
is google lens and this was the image
recognition software that we're seeing
both built into google photos and in the
camera and eventually gonna be on its
own it's pixel exclusive for now and
it's just basically starting to work on
our phones basically google lens is best
at identifying things with text in them
it's basically doing a reverse google
image search and anytime you do a
reverse google image search adding text
is really really good for narrowing down
what you're looking at so this
hasselblad photo i took is a great
example when you look at the wide-angle
photo with the whole shape of the camera
the text isn't necessarily in focus and
i hit google lens and it just kind of
knows it's a camera but when i do a
second close-up photo where you can see
the text hasselblad is more in focus
google lens definitely recognizes that
text and adds it to its search and it's
more able to properly identify what it's
looking at by adding that so overall i
didn't go out of my way to use google
lens that much but when i did it was
really cool to see it didn't really
approach me the way something like the
now playing feature did it just kind of
appeared in my face
but i think this is one of the things
that will also get better with time
especially seeing how much ai is a
forward focus with google right now i
expect it to and then number four is i
just want to say the new picture in
picture implementation for the new
youtube app on these phones is fantastic
essentially you used to hit the home
button before and it would immediately
go into background play and whatever
video you're watching would not be
visible on these phones you're watching
a youtube video you hit the home button
and it shrinks perfectly into a
picture-in-picture window that you can
still manipulate and move around the
page and use it in the background and
when you want to bring it back you can
tap on it and full screen the video
again i think it's great and then number
five the wallpapers yes the wallpapers
on this phone
are super dope normally i use an app
called backdrops if a lot of you have
been wondering where some of the
backgrounds on my phones have been
coming from lately that's the app i
usually get them from those are the
still static photos but these are
different remember live wallpapers way
back in the day on android where you
used to be able to like touch them to
interact with them when they were brand
new they were a little resource
intensive you know the powerful phones
could get away with running them in the
background but not everyone could do it
these on these new pixels are sort of
like the 2017 next level modern version
of that so you go to load up one of
these wallpapers and it looks pretty
simple at first nothing too fancy here
but if you look closely if you look
closely on this one check out the cars
driving on that road down there under
the clouds these tiny little moving
objects still going at a high frame rate
barely noticeable unless you're actually
looking at them or these these three
little i guess they're hot air balloons
flying over monument valley again super
subtle but you wouldn't even know that
they're moving unless you were looking
for them or this one my personal
favorite actually the waves crashing
down on the beach at this well-known
coastline in lagos these are sweet and
good news with this part is they aren't
pixel exclusive technically they've
already been ported out so i'll leave a
link right below that like button to get
these and put them on your own android
phone if you want them right now but
yeah there's way more stuff i have to
share with
everything from like the little things
like notifications improvements on this
phone or the stabilization in the video
camera all the way up to long-term
battery life and performance all this
will be in the full review i know i just
did a video on dxomark but the claim for
best camera in any smartphone
yeah that also does hold up here so
there's a lot to unpack expect the full
review in a couple days a little bit
down the road but this has been fun for
the uh the first impressions and the
unboxing thank you for watching
talk to you guys the next one
peace
[Music]
you